[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Okay, welcome to Radcliffe.
My name is John Huth and
I'm professor in the physics
department here at Harvard.
But I'm also a member of
the venture's faculty.
And it is a distinct delight
to be able to work and help
the programming at Radcliffe.
And I get to bring science
lectures and a science
symposium every
year to Radcliffe.
And it's wonderful to talk to
and put together the program
because I'm able to target areas
that I'm interested in and get
experts and talk to the experts
at just the right level so I
can learn something new .
And today is a perfect
example of that.
So it's a pleasure to
introduce Kerry Emanuel.
He's going to talk about
hurricanes and the titles
predicting and adapting
to hurricane risk.
I've been fascinated
with the issues of what's
happening to our planet in
particular, as the science
topics may reflect, the role
of the ocean and climate
and what it may be doing to us.
So to just confess to a
certain scientific geekiness,
about once a week, I check
out the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric
Administration's website
for the chart of the sea
surface temperature anomaly
and sometimes even paste it
up to Facebook once a week.
Some of my Facebook
friends know.
So that gives you
an idea of where
I am on the nerdy
spectrum, but that's me.
So I'm hoping to hear a
little bit more of this.
So Dr. Emanuel is the Cecil
and Ida Green Professor
of Atmospheric Sciences
at MIT, but is also
the co-director of the Edward
Lorenz institute at MIT.
And I could give you a
lot of his background
but then you'd have to listen
to all the honorific titles
associated with him.
But I will note,
among other things,
that he has written a
biography of Edward Lorenz.
And Lorenz, for those
of you who may not know,
is credited as being the
founder of chaos theory
and also there is this
famous quote from him,
does a butterfly's wings
flapping in the Brazilian rain
forest create a
tornado in Texas,
which has sparked-- I
use this in my lectures
and in fact I'm lecturing
on weather today.
So without any further
ado, Kerry Emanuel.
- Well thank you
very much, John.
It's a great pleasure to
be with you here today
to talk about one of
my favorite subjects.
I go around the country
talking about climate a lot,
but I really like
talking about hurricanes.
So what I want to
do today is to put
a little bit of a
twist on this topic
by not talking about
the storms themselves
that much, as much
as I'd like to,
but talk about how we go about
assessing risk from them.
So I want to answer
questions like,
what's the probability that
my campus, MIT, will someday
be under water in a flood?
And is that probability
evolving over time
because of climate change?
How do we go about
answering those questions?
And so that's what I sort of
like to do with you today.
So I'm going to
start off talking
a little bit about
hurricanes themselves
and the various risks that are
associated with these storms.
Then the real issue for me is
how do you quantify the risk.
How do you actually
put a number on it?
I mean, how many years
typically go by before we
get hit here in New
England, for example?
And then to talk finally
about how we expect climate
change to begin to
affect these storms.
Just so you know what
we're talking about,
this is a classic
satellite image
of a hurricane that's been
doctored by the people at NASA
to give it a kind of three
dimensional perspective.
So when you look
down from space,
you see a swirling mass of
clouds a few miles across.
And the heaviest wind,
the strongest rain
is in our annulus
that closes off
in a clear area we
know as the eye.
When you look down
from space, you're
looking at the top of
the storm about 12,
13 miles above
the ocean surface.
And you may not know this,
but the temperatures up there
are well below minus
100 degrees Fahrenheit.
It's a remarkable
thing, if you look
through the whole
atmosphere, some
of the coldest air
you can find is
in the tropical
upper atmosphere,
colder even than Antarctica.
And one of the things-- one
of the reasons that hurricanes
are so deadly and intense
has to do with the fact
that the atmosphere is
so cold near their top.
It actually makes them into
very efficient heat engines.
Now if we zoom in,
this is a photograph
taken from the Space Station
of the eye of hurricane Igor.
And once again, you
see this annulus.
We call it the eye wall for
reasons that I'll show you.
But you can see if you
go down into the eye
here that it is almost
like a circular wall.
We fly airplanes into these
storms fairly routinely
and have since the mid-1940s.
But once again, the strongest
winds, heaviest rains
are under this annulus.
In the Northern
hemisphere, the airflow
is counter-clockwise
near the surface,
but as you get to
the top of the storm
and the air begins to move out,
it actually reverses rotation
and goes the other way.
And the rotation at all levels
is reversed [? in sine ?]
in the Southern hemisphere.
This is just a little
climatology of these storms,
showing tracks of
tropical cyclones.
Tropical cyclone, by the
way, is the generic word
for this kind of event.
And hurricane is a
strictly regional name
that has very
interesting etymology
if anybody wants to talk
about it afterwards,
I can tell you
something about that.
But here is the sort of a
global pattern of these storms.
And most of us are familiar
with the Atlantic storms
here, that typically
form off Africa
all the way westward
over the Caribbean
and the Gulf of Mexico.
And they curve up.
The colors are an indication
of their wind speeds.
But only about 12% of the
world's tropical cyclones
occur in the Atlantic.
The rest occur in the
Pacific and Indian oceans.
And they don't get
quite as much coverage
in the news as the
Atlantic storms.
But the most active region
is in the Western Pacific.
They just had a horrible
typhoon, category typhoon,
go into the Northern Philippines
last week, for example.
And there are no tropical
cyclones within a few degrees
latitude of the
equator, because you
need to be able to take
the Earth's rotation axis
and project it onto
what you locally call up
and get an answer
that's not zero.
Well right on the
equator, it's zero.
So you can't have
any hurricanes there.
So if you fantasize,
as I sometimes
do when I'm sitting in my
office about some day sailing
around the world
in a nice sailboat,
and you're afraid of
tropical cyclones,
you just stick to the
equator and you'll be fine.
You may have other problems,
but not that problem.
OK, so when we
think about risks,
we like to think about three
major kinds of risks that
are associated with hurricanes.
What everybody
thinks of is wind.
The wind blows, the wind
[INAUDIBLE] very hard,
and structures
aren't necessarily
designed to cope with
winds in this country
much over 100 miles an
hour, and they fail.
And that is a big
source of damage.
But it is surprisingly not, by
any means, the most lethal form
of damage, particularly
in the developing world.
Actually the second
deadliest aspect
of hurricanes, which
I'm constantly--
and my colleagues are constantly
trying to drum into the public
is this boring thing
called rain, right?
The Weather Channel
doesn't usually
send their weather forecasters
out to stand in a rainstorm,
because it's boring and they
want the drama of the wind.
But this is what kills.
All right?
And we have unfortunately
lots and lots
of bad examples of that,
even recently in US history.
But if you go back to
1998, Hurricane Mitch,
which went into Central America,
killed about 12,000 people.
12,000, OK?
It was all from freshwater
flooding caused by rain.
One death occurred because
of wind in that event.
But historically the most
lethal is the storm surge.
This is what got people in New
Orleans in Katrina and New York
in Sandy, but tragically in
other parts of the world,
like the Philippines a few
years ago, when Haiyan went in.
The storm surge is
what people find
most difficult to envision.
And so to try to get you to
understand what it looks like,
I'm going to play you
a short film clip.
And what you're going
to see is a storm surge
associated with
Haiyan, photographed
by an amateur who happened
to have a video camera.
And hydrodynamically, it is
the same thing as a tsunami.
It's just that it hasn't
been caused by shaking earth
but by blowing wind.
But when it happens,
it's the same thing,
except it occurs in the
middle of a typhoon.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So this is a storm.
Now I think you can imagine that
that's impossible to survive,
if you're caught in it.
That's what kills
the most people.
[END PLAYBACK]
And yet we're
forever trying to get
people to take that seriously.
And I think it's partially
because they can't envision it
that they don't take
warnings of this phenomenon
all that seriously.
So if you can imagine a tsunami
in the middle of a typhoon,
that's what a storm surge is.
So we want to try to quantify,
to actually put numbers
on the risk of storm surges in
different parts of the world.
Now if you just look at
the damage from hurricanes.
Globally, on average, it's
about 10,000 people a year.
Of course these are concentrated
in a handful of events
every few years.
And $700 billion in 2015
US dollars annually, OK?
So that's a lot of money.
And globally, this
is the partitioning
of insured losses for a
particular year, 2006,
by natural phenomena
of the floods,
79 percent windstorms, of which
most of that is hurricanes
and other phenomena.
Now this can be
a bit misleading,
on the other hand, because
private insurance in most
countries doesn't
cover earthquakes
and often doesn't cover floods.
But it usually does
cover hurricanes.
And so for that reason,
the big insurance companies
and the reinsurance industry
is pretty much paranoid
about hurricanes.
And they're always after
me and my colleagues
to tell them more about them.
We have a big problem
with hurricanes
in the United States, a really
big problem historically.
And that's indicated
in this graph, which
shows the damage
in 2004 US dollars,
corrected for inflation,
but not otherwise corrected,
by decade, from the first
decade of the 20th century
to the first decade
of the 21st century.
And you can see this really,
really big increase in damage.
This is sort of going
up geometrically.
And there's no particular
mystery, on the other hand,
about why that's happening.
And it's not because hurricanes
are changing, or at least
not changing enough
to cause that.
It's just because
coastal populations
are going up much faster than
the population as a whole.
OK?
This is the population of
Florida from 1790 to 2004.
And you can see
this huge increase
that really began to
accelerate in the 1950s,
thanks to the invention
of the air conditioner,
which made Florida
habitable by mere mortals.
But that's the big problem.
And policies that are in place
in the United States actively
subsidize people to move to
and build in dangerous places.
And that's going to cause a
string of Sandys and Katrinas
as far as the eye can
see, having nothing
to do with climate change.
Climate change just
makes it worse.
In the United States we have a
huge hurricane policy problem.
Now my colleague, Roger Pielke,
at the University of Colorado,
tried to correct the
damages to account
for changing population and
infrastructure, in addition
to changing wealth, and gets
this sort of normalized graph
of hurricane damages.
You can see the spectacular
damages in the 1920s.
That was largely from one event,
the Miami hurricane of 1926,
which put that city under water.
But the first decade
of the 21st century
is also very bad in this rank.
Now here is the US damage
over that whole period of time
by the category of
storm at landfall.
The Saffer-Simpon
Category is a measure
of how strong the
winds are, basically.
You probably are
familiar with this.
But you can see
most of the damage
is done by Category 3
and 4 and to some extent
Category 5 storms.
But those storms are in a
pretty small minority of events.
So this is just the number of
events whose landfall Category
is given on this axis.
So most of the storms
making landfall in the US
are Category 1 and Category 2.
They're relatively weak and
they don't do very much damage.
We're pretty hardened
to those storms by now.
It's the much rarer
Category 3, 4, and 5 storms.
So here's the nature
of the problem.
More than half of the normalized
damage over the last 150 years
is done by eight storms.
Eight.
OK?
That's not a lot of
numbers to do statistics
with if you're a statistician.
And more than 90%
are caused by storms
of Category 3 and
higher, which only
constitute 13% of the events.
So the conclusion that
we get and that we
try to drum into the
insurance companies,
is all you want to do is do
it from an actuarial basis,
look at historical
statistics, determine
everything, like your
property insurance premium,
based on that.
It's a fool's game.
The history isn't long enough.
And I haven't even started
to tell you how imperfect
that history is in terms
of the quality of the data.
So, is there something we
can do to put some more
teeth onto this whole
problem of hurricane risk?
Can we do a better
job than just looking
at historical statistics?
Well, yes, I think we can.
And there are two
main approaches.
One is to ask, what can we learn
from the geological record?
Do hurricanes leave a
signature in that record?
And what can we learn from that?
Now this is not work
that I do, but it's work
that I strongly support.
And this field is called
paleotempestology.
And in fact, my only
contribution to that field
was to invent that word.
But there are
various techniques.
And probably the
most published one
is this, that-- I just showed
you a film of a storm surge.
And if you imagine
a coastline, which
you find many examples that
are like this in the US East
and Gulf Coasts, where
you have the ocean here
and a beach or bunch of sand
dunes, and then behind that
you often have either a marsh
or a lake or a lagoon or both.
And normally, during
quiescent periods,
you have things growing in
the lagoon and in the marsh
and they die and
they settle down.
They create this very
nice rich, organic mud.
But when there is a
hurricane, the storm surge
washes some of the sand into
these marshes and lagoons.
And then you resume burying
it with organic material.
So if you get a rubber
dinghy and load it up
with graduate students
and go out in the lagoon
and take a core, you
can see the sand layers.
And you can radiocarbon
date the mud around them
and that will tell you
when those sand layers were
put down.
So this has been
done and is still
being done around the country.
And we're really beginning to
learn some interesting things.
I want to show
you one site which
is at the head of Apalachee
Bay in Florida here,
where the star is, where
there is a kind of a sinkhole,
and sand being washed
into the sinkhole
by hurricanes over
a period of time.
And so we get a record
that looks like this.
So this is going back in time.
So this is 2000 BC.
This is 0.
And then this is the
present, 2000 Ad.
And each of these
spikes, which represent
how coarse the material
is in the core, it's
kind of a measure of how much
sand you have, is denoted by--
is here.
And some of the more
recent ones correspond
to known historical events.
There's Elena that went ashore
there in the 80s, Dennis
more recently.
And then back in
the 18th century,
there was a famous
storm that wrecked
an entire Spanish fleet
commanded by Solano,
so it's called Solano's storm.
And that shows up
in this record.
But you can see that
there are periods,
for example the
first 1,000 years
BC, where there was a
lot more activity, also
during the sort of medieval
warm period in here
there was a lot more activity.
And so we think,
just based on that,
that we're underestimating
long term hurricane
risk in that
particular place today
because we happen to be in
a relatively quiet period.
OK?
So that's one way of doing it.
But that only gives you a
few points along the coast.
That doesn't really tell you
what's happening globally.
And so we turn to
another technique,
which is to try to bring
physics to bear on the problem.
After all, we do
understand quite a bit more
than we used to about how
hurricanes work to the extent
that we can simulate
them with models.
But there is a technical
problem with this.
So if we try to use a
climate model, for example,
a global model to
simulate them, it
turns out they're
just too coarse.
These equations are solved
on a computational lattice
whose computational points
are typically 100 miles apart.
And that's just
way too much, too
coarse to resolve the critical
eye wall region of a hurricane.
In fact, we know from
lots of experiments
we need to be down
in the one mile
range of our computational
grid to be able to simulate
hurricanes accurately.
So if you go ahead
and try to do it,
you get kind of bad answers.
So what you see on this
chart is wind speed.
Now this is in
meters per second.
If you like knots, if you're
a sailor, if you double this
you'll just about get knots.
And this is the frequency of
storms with this wind speed.
The black is what we
observe in nature.
This black line is the
division between Category 2
and lower in Category
3 and higher.
And the red is what's
modeled by global models.
So what this tells us is
that the destructive storms,
remember the ones to the right
of this curve, these storms
here, we don't even model those.
So the very storms
we're interested in,
we can't simulate
with a global model.
Now, maybe 20 years
from now, given
the advance in the
speed of computers,
we'll be able to do that.
But right now we can't do it.
We only can simulate weak
sort of sloppy storms.
And that's with the state
of the art climate model.
So global models don't simulate
the destructive storms.
So what we've done
at MIT is an approach
that sometimes
called downscaling,
where you embed
within the hurricane
model, the global model, a very
specialized hurricane model.
So this is one that was
developed over the years,
first as a laboratory tool, then
it was adopted by the National
Hurricane Center
to help forecast
and still does help them
forecast real storms.
And I don't want to go bore you
with a lot of technical detail
about this.
But it has very high
resolution and it critically
interacts with the ocean.
You know hurricanes stir up
cold water from the depths
and that helps limit
their intensity.
And you have to simulate
that if you want
to do hurricanes accurately.
So what we do is to
embed these little baby
hurricane models--
there's a lot more to it
than I have time to explain--
within the time evolving fields
produced by a global model
or global climate analysis
data set.
And we can generate
hundreds of thousands
of synthetic events that way.
And of course it's all
very well and good to say
you can do that.
But how do you know
you've got it right?
Well there you do have
to use history to ask,
do you get the right
distribution of storms?
So this is an example of a
mere 1000 tracks produced
by this method where we
embed the hurricane model not
in a climate model
but in a climate data
set, an actual data set
of the current climate.
And it's similar to the
tracks I showed you before.
The colors are an
indication of intensity.
Now of course those of you who
have seen hurricane charts--
I expect you have John,
given your proclivities
for looking at maps like these,
but-- this looks pretty good.
But of course you want to
do much more rigorous tests
on this than you can do by once
over lightly with the eyeball.
But this is kind of
a low level check.
And we've done lots
and lots of statistics.
And the technique works
surprisingly well.
This shows you the origin
points of these simulated storms
versus real storms.
And you can see similarities
and differences.
The greatest differences
are that there
are a lot of storms
in the observations
up in this region
here, including
right off of Long Island.
And we know that can't be true,
because tropical cyclones never
develop off of Long Island.
That shows you that
there are perils
in doing this comparison.
The observations
aren't always right.
The analysts put in to the
mix nor'easters, which are not
the same thing as hurricanes.
And so you have to be
very careful about how
you do these comparisons.
Now once you have
this technique,
you can generate--
you can filter storms,
so that, for example, here
are 200 hurricane tracks that
happen to pass close enough to
where we're all sitting today
to affect the region.
And then we can-- if we're
interested in hurricanes
in Boston, we can produce
event sets like this,
and start to really put
some numbers on the risk.
Now, what we like to do is
to compare those statistics
with historical
statistics in places
where there are
enough historical data
to make that viable.
And that gives us some
confidence that this works.
So here is an example of a
storm that affects Boston.
It's just one out of many
thousands of simulated storms.
The color again
shows you a measure
of how strong the winds are.
These are dates in September.
So this particular
event, characteristic
of all strong hurricanes
in New England,
is moving very, very
quickly to the north.
It covers territory
from off the Carolinas
to New Hampshire in one day.
So it's really moving fast.
Here is something
called a wind swath.
This is just the contours of
the strongest wind experience
at any point during this one
event that I just showed you.
So, for example,
in Boston Harbor
there are winds of 85 knots
or so with this event,
which is a respectable
hurricane for New England.
The event itself
follows along this.
The center of the storm
goes up this black line.
And as usual for New
England hurricanes,
the strong winds are all
to the right of the track,
whereas a lot of the rain
is to the left of the track.
Speaking of rain, this
model does produce rain.
Remember rain is the
second biggest killer.
We're worried about that.
This storm is moving
very fast so it
didn't produce very much rain.
But here you see contours of
storm accumulated rainfall
in millimeters.
So you can see the effects of
topography and other things
that are known to
affect rainfall there.
Well, the beauty
of this is that we
can go way beyond history
in estimating things
like the rare events.
So here is an estimate of
something called the return
periods for storms affecting
the whole New England coastline.
And so this is the
return period in years.
And that's
technically-- it's just
the inverse annual
probability of storms.
So the way to interpret 100
is that a return period of 100
is a probability of
1% in a given year
that you will have a
storm of that intensity.
So we see that there's
a 1% probability
that you'll have a storm in any
given year affecting the New
England coastline
with winds of around
105 nautical miles per hour.
The green dots are
inferences made strictly
on historical data.
And the blue dots come
from these synthetic events
I just described.
The red is just a
curve fit to that.
So you can get much
further out because you
have many, many more events.
So you can look at much
rarer events of the kind that
usually cause the most damage.
Now I mentioned to you that
the most lethal aspect,
on the other hand, of
hurricanes is the storm surge.
So we haven't said anything
about how to model those,
but in fact, that
is a very advanced--
that particular bit of
computational fluid dynamics
is very advanced.
My profession has
gotten very good
at simulating storm
surges given that you
know what the hurricane's
doing, obviously.
So if you have a known
hurricane, you can do that.
And here is an
example of a series
of simulations for
the city of New York
that we did some years ago.
And this circular area
here shows an example
of the computational
mesh that was used
to do the surge simulations.
And the dots, blue and
red dots [INAUDIBLE],
is a different model, a
much more sophisticated one,
which has an adaptive, or
sorry, an unstructured mesh.
And the beauty about
storm surge modeling
is the equations are very
simple, for those of you who
do any kind of modeling.
On the other hand, the
boundary conditions
are hopelessly complicated.
So it's an interesting
computational challenge.
But I think it's
been largely met.
So we can use these thousands
of artificial hurricanes,
if you will, to drive storm
surges using models like this
and get an estimate of
the risk of storm surges.
And we did a study for
Manhattan back in 2010.
It's before Sandy, actually.
And this was our estimate
of the peak surge
at the Battery, which is at
the southern tip of New York
and happens to
have a tide gauge.
So these things
are measured there.
And this again is return period
so this is one in 100 years,
one in 500 years, one in 5,000
years, one in 50,000 years.
And this is the level
of the surge in meters.
OK?
So Sandy's surge was
about 2.8 meters.
And so we would have
estimated that that
was like a 600 or 700 year event
that we saw for the Battery.
It doesn't mean
you wouldn't have
to wait that long to see a surge
that magnitude somewhere around
there, but right at the
Battery-- and other people
using completely
different methods
have come up with
similar estimates.
So Sandy was a rare, rare event.
And we did this before Sandy.
All right.
So we can do rain, we can do
wind, we can do storm surge.
And we're starting to
try to put together
what the actual
risk is in places
all around the
world, including most
recently in my own backyard.
I finally got MIT
to realize that they
have a substantial flooding
risk from these kinds of events,
including the fact
that the control
room for our nuclear reactor
is underground and not very far
from the Charles River.
So I'm trying to get them
to pay attention to that.
But slowly it's happening.
Now I want to talk
about climate change.
And I don't have a long time
to introduce the subject.
A lot of you have
heard a lot about it.
And I'm not really here to
talk about that, per se.
But I did want to mention that
this is an old subject, not
a new one.
And arguably, the
first scientists
who worried about the fact that
we were changing the climate
was this man, Svante Arrhenius,
a gifted Swedish chemist,
who won a Nobel
Prize in chemistry,
who lived at the end of the 19th
and the early 20th centuries.
And he wrote a paper
in 1906 in which
he, using measurements
of moonlight,
and pencil and paper-- this was
good old fashioned 19th century
science-- came to the
conclusion that if we succeeded
in doubling the carbon dioxide
content of the atmosphere,
we would raise the earth's
surface temperature by about
4 degrees C. And if
we quadrupled it,
it would go up 8 degrees.
They were slightly
higher estimates
than ones he had done about
eight years before that,
nine years before that.
But given that, with all of our
computers and the whole IPCC
process, we're two
degrees to 4.5 degrees
is the current
range-- he did this
without computers, with
pencil and papers pretty good.
So was he right?
I think the data are pretty
persuasive about this.
This green curve is the Earth's
mean surface temperature
from thermometers going back
to the late 19th century.
And the blue curve is a
measure of the carbon dioxide
content of the atmosphere.
And you can see that there's
a lot of chaotic variability.
John mentioned to
you Ed Lorenz, who
was very interested in this.
There are also things
I haven't shown
you on this diagram, volcanic
eruptions and so forth.
But by and large, the
surface temperature
has followed carbon
dioxide, as we
know it did in the geological
past, so we have a problem.
And a lot of work
has gone into trying
to quantify all kinds of
risks associated with this,
but I'm here today to talk
about hurricane risks.
Now before I show you what
this particular model has
to say about that, let me
say that all the way back
in the late 1980s,
we understood,
just from the basic
theory of hurricanes
as heat engines, just engines
for taking in this case
the heat energy from the
ocean and converting it
into the kinetic
energy of winds,
would have to go up if
you warm the climate
by almost any means
you can think of,
the sun, CO2, so forth.
There's a speed
limit for hurricanes.
And it's dictated by the
thermodynamics of that engine.
And that speed limit goes
up as you put carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere.
So we understood
that theoretically.
But there's an awful lot of
other things that can change,
the tracks of
storms and so forth.
And so we'd like
to try to, again,
try to put some numbers on this.
So what we do is we
apply this technique
I just described to you, rather
than to climatological data
sets, to global climate models.
And we are using at
the moment seven models
chosen because of
the availability
of the actual output we
need to run our technique.
And I'm going to look
at-- primarily compare
historical period storms to
end of this century storms
under a kind of business as
usual emissions scenario.
If you look globally, this is
a measure of global hurricane
or tropical cyclone power.
This is actually a hindcase
going back to 1980.
And then this is
a prediction going
to the end of this century.
And you can see that there
is in-- this shading is
a scatter among the seven
models that we applied this to.
So you can see there's
considerable scatter.
But in general there seems to
be an upward trend, as theory
told us there should be.
So here is a very
rare event that
occurs in one of
these models that
affects Boston at the end
of this century, 2,086,
in August and September.
And so you can see that now--
and again this even then
would be an
extraordinarily rare event,
but it's actually possible
at the end of the century
to get a Cat 5 hurricane in
Boston, according to this.
Unlikely, but possible.
And there's the wind swath
associated with that event.
And the wind speed and direction
on the 4th to 5th of September
at Logan Airport.
So wind is ramping up.
This is in knots.
It's a little bit more
than a mile per hour,
if you aren't used
to those units.
It ramps up.
It goes all the way
up to about 130 knots.
Then the eye passes over.
And then this is the
backside of the eye wall.
And this is the
wind direction here.
But it's a very,
very rare event.
And that's an event
that would not
be able to happen physically
in today's climate.
So if we want to really try to
get down to the nuts and bolts,
this is showing-- in this case,
you have to adjust yourself.
This is the return period here
of storms-- of tropical storm
hurricane Cat 1, Cat 2, Cat
3, all the way to Cat 5.
This is the return
period of storms
passing within 150
kilometers of here,
based on five climate models.
The blue is for the climate
of the late 20th century
and the red is for the climate
of the late 21st century.
So for example, a Cat 5
passing within 150 kilometers
in the current climate
is virtually impossible.
You know, it's a 1 in
200,000 year event, 1
in 200,000 chance each
year of having an event,
basically impossible.
But it becomes something
like a one in 900 year event
by the end of the century.
The shading, again, is the
scatter among, in this case,
the five climate models that
we applied the technique to.
And so an event that's a 100
[? knot ?] of Category 2 events
might be expected once per
100 years, on the average.
By the end of the century
it's more like once a decade.
So there's a big change.
I was a bit surprised
to see that.
Rain is much more clear cut.
As the year gets warmer,
there's more water vapor in it,
and a given storm can rain more.
Doesn't mean that annual
rainfall will go up,
but you have storms
that produce more rain.
This is the same kind of curve.
It's just for this total
storm rainfall in millimeters.
This again is for Boston,
the current climate,
future climate.
So 1,000 year event, at the
end of the 20th century,
becomes every 50
years or something
like that at the
end of this century.
That's something that
virtually all techniques show,
is that the risk of really
heavy rainstorms of just about
any kind goes up in many places
because of this phenomenon.
This is the same kind of
thing, but for storm surge
in Boston Harbor.
So once again, this is
the peak surge in meters.
It's not as big as you
can get in New York.
This is for the current
climate and this
is for the future climate.
And this is all because of
changes in the character
of the hurricanes.
We haven't put sea level
rise into this yet,
and that's a big deal.
And I'll show you
that in a minute.
But for example, a surge of
2 meters in Boston Harbor
is actually hard to
do with a hurricane.
We're more at risk of
nor'easters in Boston.
But by the end of the century,
that becomes every few hundred
years.
But sea level is going up.
So this is a global sea
level, relative to what it was
in 2000, going back to 1980.
This is in feet in this chart.
That's what's
happened, and that's
what's projected to happen.
So we could have a few
feet rise in sea level,
but with a lot of uncertainty.
And unfortunately, it's going
up faster in certain places,
including New England, than
it's going up globally.
Sea level rise is
not globally uniform.
Far from it.
There are actually places,
like South of Greenland,
where the sea level is falling.
And so somebody might want
to ask me a question later,
why should sea level be
falling South of Greenland?
OK?
Kind of an interesting
story there.
So if we build a
one meter sea level
rise, globally or in
Boston, into that and then
we get these huge differences
in surge, not surprisingly,
so a 10,000 year event becomes
every couple of centuries.
For example, in Boston.
And an event that you might
experience once in 500 years,
you basically have
it every year,
because one meter is already
built into the system.
So it's there permanently.
Now once you have
numbers like this,
you can start to convert
them into other things
that you might be interested in.
For example, monetary losses.
And Michael Bloomberg and Hank
Paulson and a few other people
commissioned a rather
thorough economic analysis
of the costs of climate
change a couple of years ago.
And I was part of that effort.
I sort of worked on the
hurricane aspect of this very
comprehensive report.
So what we see here
for the whole US
is the increase in
average annual losses
due to hurricanes.
And this increases in
billions of dollars.
So by 2030, we can have just
maybe a few billion dollars
increase over what we're
already experiencing.
The green is for-- I should say
the blue is for sea level rise
alone, without any changes
in hurricane characteristics,
and the green includes
changing hurricanes.
So by the end of
the century, if we
include changing
hurricane statistics,
we're looking at an additional
average $70 billion a year
loss.
And so planners are very
interested in numbers
like that.
So let me try to bring
it down, finally,
to the level where it
might mean something.
What are you going
to do about this?
So I'm not going to get
into the whole issue,
should we try to
control climate change.
If you're the mayor of a city,
like the mayor of New York,
that's not your problem.
Your problem is how do you make
the city resilient or robust
to this sort of thing.
So they've actually done a
lot more work in New York
than we've done here in
Boston and they've actually
started to cost out various
options for preparing New York
City for this kind of
thing in the future.
So what you see here
are some proposals.
If you might recognize, this
is a map of the New York Metro
area.
There's Staten Island,
Manhattan is here, Brooklyn,
and so forth.
And so one of the options is
to build some storm barriers.
This is a fantastic one.
It goes all the way from
the Rockaways to New Jersey.
OK?
There are much smaller versions
of this all around the country,
including most
spectacularly New Bedford,
if you've ever been down there
to see their storm barrier.
But this is a really
big version and they
have to build a
small one up here
at the head of
Long Island Sound.
And they shut those
gates if a storm comes.
And they've actually
costed that out.
I helped them do that.
Another strategy is to
forget about doing that,
build some much more
modest barriers,
but harden a lot of the
infrastructure of the city,
make it possible to keep
water out of the subways,
move generators from the
basements of buildings
to the rooftop,
emergency generators,
so they don't go out just when
you need them and so forth.
Now what option
you decide to do,
if you're a resident of the
city of New York, a voter there,
is a perplexing
question, because it
depends upon your time
scale and also depends on
your assumption about
how the economics
of the city and the country will
evolve over the next 100 years.
So you know something
about the discount rate.
So I don't want to
bore you with this,
but these are sort of
benefit cost ratios for four
different kinds of solutions.
And this is for the
current climate,
this is for climate change.
There are a lot of
numbers up here.
But the bottom line is if you're
only worried about the next 50
years, harden the
buildings, and that's
about the best you can do.
If you want to take an
optimistic point of view
in terms of the economy
and wait, then 50 years,
later you build
the storm barrier.
And that will see you through
the next 50 or 100 years.
Now again, voters
have to decide this.
It's our job-- not my
job because I'm not
an economist, thank God.
But the economist's
job is to understand
how to convey to the public
what particular benefit is going
to cost what
amount, so that they
can make intelligent decisions.
All right, so I
hope I've given you
a little bit of a taste
for where we're going.
This is taking the physical
problem of hurricanes--
and hurricanes are really
beautiful for physicists.
OK?
As deadly as they
are, they're really
neat phenomena to understand.
I'd love to talk to
you about that today.
But I think it's important
also to take what we've
learned about physics and
about modeling storms,
and actually start to use
it to understand risk.
And it's kind of an
interesting thing
to do because there are
physical modelers over
on that side of the
room and they're
risk modelers over
in the other corner
and they hardly ever
talk to each other.
Because the risk
modelers are all doing it
based on historical statistics.
They're statisticians looking
at actuarial approaches
to this, right?
And the physicists weren't
worried about risk.
They just want to know
how the thing works.
And some of us have
tried to bridge this
and it's actually turning into
a very fascinating endeavor.
So let me summarize.
Hurricane history,
even in the US,
where it's arguably the best
historically, is too short.
And I didn't really
talk about it,
but the hurricane
records are pretty bad.
So when you put
those together it's
really tough to come up with
quantitative assessments
of hurricane risk strictly
from historical data.
You can make better
estimates-- although I'm not
sure we're there yet--
potentially you can make better
estimates by looking at
the geological record
and making deductions from that.
There are other
techniques I didn't
talk about today which are even
more fantastic for doing this.
So there's some hope that we're
going to get learn something
about hurricanes from looking
at a 7000 year history
rather than just a
100 year history.
And then in many
places, hurricane risk
is expected to increase
to this century.
There are places where
we expect it to fall,
but by and large
we see increases.
Coastal impacts of hurricanes,
whether they change or not,
are made much worse
by sea level rise.
And I should say here
that in the United States,
we have a peculiar
and very worrying
problem, that would be a problem
if there was no climate change.
It's the confluence of two
bad trends, one of which
is actually climate related,
rising sea level and big time
rising coastal populations,
accompanied by policies that
greatly underwrite
the risk people take
when they move to the coast.
I love the sea, so it's a
terrible dilemma for me.
But the fact is that
we're going to bring about
lots and lots more hurricane
disasters just through policy.
We call them natural disasters,
but that's not correct.
Nature got used to these
events a long time ago.
There are disasters
for us because we
insist upon building stuff and
living in dangerous places.
That's the bottom line.
If we're simply going
to adapt to the changes,
that pathway is very
dependent upon where you are.
What works for New York may
be a disaster for Boston,
and vice versa, and
also on your viewpoint.
Is it you just care
about the economy today?
Or do you care about the economy
that your kids and grandkids
will experience?
So it's all a bit subjective,
and from an economical point
of view also, assumptions
about discount rates.
And hurricanes are just
one of many problems
that we have to
try to understand,
in terms of their risk and
how to mitigate them and adapt
to them.
So I'll leave you
with those thoughts,
and I'm happy to take questions
[MUSIC PLAYING]